استقبال حافل حضور جماهري غفير وتحيه
عربيه واصوات تعلو لتقول لكريستيانو
رونالدو مرحبا في السعوديه ضيفا ونجما
وناعبا للنادي العالمي نادي النصر السعودي
رونالدو الذي كان يعلم موعد تاريخي مع
الجماهير السعوديه رد بلغه يفهمها الجمهور
انا عالمي استاذ منصور بارك كان الواحه
التي استقرت فيها مسيره نجوميه لرونالدو
وحفيتها التي قادته الى اختيار المشروع
الرياضي السعودي اليوم رونالدو عندنا في
المنطقه هنا في الرياض لتقول الاجيال
الجديده الحلم اكبر المشروع اجمل وقت كبير
[تصفيق]
مال الذهب الا رجال
ومال النصر غير
البطن بخلال يا شاغل الدنيا السنين
ها العب ولا تحسب للارقام
حسبان مال الذهب
الارجل فشيله ومال النصر غير البطوله تخلى
[موسيقى]
العب ولا تحسب للارقام حسب
[تصفيق]
المحسن الحربي عبد المحسنين اهلا بك
استقبال مبهردون هو اين انت الان يا عبد
المحسن اولا وسام مصر يعرفونك انت تفضل
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير نادين وسهام انا اتواجد اليوم
في المكان الذي بالمتوقع بنسبه كبيره جدا
ان يكون فيه كريستيانو
وعائلته على الدوام في الرياض حيث حي
المحمديه الذي هو مرشح
بنسبه كبيره جدا
لان يكون مقر السكن الدائم لكريستيانو
رونالدو في هذا الحي بعد ان وصل الى
الرياض قبل يومين
وكذلك همم يوم الامس تحديدا تم الاحتفاء
به بشكل كبير في ملعب مرسول مبارك وتم
تقديمه بشكل رسمي الى جمهور نادي النصر
والجمهور السعودي بشكل عام بهذا الاحتفاء
الكبير الذي اقيم يوم الامس ومتوقع طبعا
ان كريستيانو رونالدو يدخل الى همم قائمه
الفريق الى الايام القادمه لممثل النصر
بشكل رسمي
يعني واضحه عليك الله يديم السعاده عليك
شو كمان حابب تعطينا معلومات الناس مثلا
حابه تعرفها لا حياه كريستيانو رونالدو
كيف هتكون في الرياض وين راح يكون بالضبط
وهل فعلا الاشاعات اللي عم تسمعها انه
البيت هيكون فيه متاجر ومول همم ولهذه بس
اشاعات
مطاعم كمان
سعيد بقدوم كريستيانو رونالدو وهو يعني حد
اساطير كره القدم فبالتالي ان تشاهده في
بلادك هذا شيء غير عادي وغير طبيعي فبالك
بان تشاهده في احد النوادي التي تحبها
لكثير من السعوديين بالنسبه للنقطه التي
تحدثت فيها نادين في الحقيقه كان هناك
حديث كبير جدا عن هذا النوع وتحديدا
الحياه كريستيانو في الرياض كيف ستكون على
الاقل خلال الاشهر القليله القادمه ولكن
كريستيانو الان هو موجود في احد الفنادق
همم الفاخره في السعوديه همم حيث همم كان
همم متواجد في هذا الفندق مباشره عند
وصوله بعد ان همم بعد ان همم يمكث في ذلك
المكان وفي ظل هذا الوقت هو يتم تجهيزره
بالفعل هو يتم تجهيز مكان قامته في الرياض
المرشح بشكل كبير هذا الحيه الذي نتواجد
به حي المحمديه الذي يحتوي على العديد من
القصور في الحقيقه هذا بيقول مشهد الطبيعي
لهذا الحي عديد من القصور عديد من البيوت
ذات المساحات الشاسعه فبالتالي هو مرشح
همم بنسبه كبيره جدا ان يكون كريستيانو في
هذا الحي وبنزل في همم بمساحه ايضا كبيره
حتى الان المعلومات الوارده او المنتشره
همم ليست حقيقيه همم حتى هذه اللحظه ما
يتحدث عن الوجود مول وجود عدد من همم ولكن
الذي سيكون متوفر بحسب المعلومات الاوليه
التي حصلنا عليها بان كريستيانو سيكون
لديه قصر سيكون لديه مساحه كبيره في داخل
المنزل سيكون لديه همم نادي ومسبح واا
الاهلي يمارس ايضا التدريبات
خلال الاوقات الدافئه في الرياض ايضا نادي
يمارس ايضا همم الرياضه وعدد من همم مرافق
في داخل قصره في الرياض او مكان سكنه اذا
صح التعبير وهو مكان كبير جدا همم في سواء
كان هنا في حي محمديه او حتى الحي الاخر
المرشح وهو حي النخيل الذي يتواجد به عدد
كبير من المدارس العالميه لتالي رونالدو
ممكن ان يكون في هذا الحي او في الحي
الاخر نظرا لوجود مدارس العالميه في ذلك
المكان همم وامكانيات دخول ابنائه الى تلك
المدارس
وين بدنا نعيش في الرياض شكرا جزيلا لك
عبد المحسن الحربي مراسل صباح العربيه